ukraine has appealed to the world for
help in the aftermath of the russian
invasion
the ukrainian military was large before
the invasion they had more than 196 000
active military personnel but the
russian military dwarfs this so the
ukrainian government has appealed to
other countries for help
so who has sent military aid
[Music]
you could say they need everything but
the things that would make the most
difference to the immediate problems
ukrainian forces face
are anti-armor weapons and anti-aircraft
weapons because what they've got coming
at them as they hunker down in their
cities
are tanks and armoured vehicles
and air attack and so anything that can
actually even up the score of it
particularly in urban areas where the
defenders do have some natural
advantages
would be welcomed
well since january the united kingdom
has been sending military aid to ukraine
2000 anti-tank missiles called next
generation light anti-tank weapons were
airlifted in with around 30 troops to
train ukrainians
other equipment like body armor helmets
and combat boots has also been sent
since then the uk has promised to
increase its military support
the uk will shortly be providing a
further package of military support to
ukraine
this will include lethal aid in the form
of defensive weapons and non-lethal aid
on the 25th of february the u.s
president joe biden pledged an extra 350
million dollars in military support for
ukraine
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences the united states has
reportedly provided more than 2.5
billion dollars in military aid to
ukraine since 2014.
that includes equipment like anti-tank
missiles patrol boats humvees sniper
rifles drones and radar systems
now for the first time ever the european
union is providing military aid to a
country it's coming via the european
peace facility the eu has pledged 450
million euros worth of weapons with
member countries pledging equipment like
anti-tank weapons surface-to-air
missiles jeeps and machine guns the eu
has also promised 50 million euros worth
of non-lethal equipment like fuel
helmets personal protective equipment
and first aid kits
in a monumental policy change the german
government has also sent military
assistance to ukraine i'm done president
putin with them
of the ukraine
they're sending a thousand anti-tank
weapons and 500 stinger missiles which
are being used to bring down russian
aircraft
it's a major shift away from the
country's ban on weapon exports to
conflict zones
and in another major change of policy
sweden has decided to send 5000
anti-tank weapons as well as body armor
ammunition and field rations now sweden
is historically neutral and is not a
part of nato but following comments from
the russian foreign minister
spokesperson it's obvious that the
accession of finland and sweden to nato
which is primarily a military
organization would have serious military
and political consequences that would
require our country to take reciprocal
steps
sweden decided to send aid
military aid has also been sent or
pledged by these countries they will
mostly be delivered via land
it's not difficult to get weapons into
ukraine through poland and romania and
nato has made big efforts now to do that
actually been sending them for quite
some time through those routes they have
to be hidden um and hiding large numbers
of weapons is really quite difficult so
we must expect as this fighting goes on
that it will become more difficult for
western weapons to reach ukrainian
forces in the time scale they've got to
use them properly and that time scale is
probably
not much more than let's say two or
maybe three weeks
the russian forces have been hitting
cities across ukraine with shells and
missiles
they've now deployed much more
capability to inflict wider and more
indiscriminate harm
tanks and armored vehicles have also
been seen on the streets accompanied by
both long-range precision missiles and
some of the most powerful artillery
weapons in the world
russia has a very active arms industry
itself which has designed bureaus for
aircraft and ships tanks everything
in fact russia is the third biggest arms
exporter in the world so the russians
got no problem in producing their own
weapons the ukrainian ambassador to the
uk has claimed that russia has also used
thermobaric weapons in this invasion now
they're also known as a vacuum bomb they
suck up oxygen and cause a huge
explosion they're known to be able to
vaporize human bodies
cluster munitions also appear to have
been used they're a form of air-dropped
or ground-launched explosive that
releases or rejects smaller submunitions
of course there is the ever-present if
highly unlikely threat that if things
escalate chemical or even nuclear
weapons could be used the ukrainian
military and its people have put up a
much tougher resistance than vladimir
putin was ever expecting but as russia
increases its military might and its
stranglehold on the country and the
ukrainians tire from days of fighting
this war could descend into urban
conflict leading to mass displacement
and greater destruction